[Música]
el secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken viaja a europa para intentar
bajar las tensiones entre ucrania y
rusia el funcionario se reunirá con su
homólogo ruso serguéi lávrov en ginebra
el viernes por otra parte el
departamento de estado estadounidense
advierte de los peligros de los
ejercicios militares conjuntos entre
rusia y belarús
el diente y ver visión acordaron
postergar el encendido de algunas torres
inalámbricas de la red 5g cerca de
aeropuertos en eeuu la intención es
evitar un supuesto caos que temen los
operadores aéreos la casa blanca pidió
soluciones que minimicen los riesgos y
las perturbaciones
la pandemia está lejos de terminar así
lo advirtió la organización mundial de
la salud y explicó que la variante
omicron no sólo se está expandiendo sino
que es probable que surjan nuevos
linajes sólo la semana pasada se
confirmaron 18 millones de contagios en
todo el mundo
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24
yo soy la calle y es un placer
saludarlos y el máximo representante de
la diplomacia estadounidense anthony
blinken viaja hacia europa en un intento
por reducir las tensiones entre rusia y
ucrania él se encontrará con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
antes de verse cara a cara con su
homólogo ruso serguéi lávrov en ginebra
rusia sigue negando cualquier intención
de invadir a ucrania pero el
departamento de estado estadounidense
ahora se muestra preocupado por el
despliegue de tropas rusas en belarús
donde se realizarán ejercicios militares
conjuntos el informe es de manuela cano
unas tensiones que están lejos de acabar
a pesar de los intentos diplomáticos
entre rusia y los países occidentales
todavía no hay una salida clara para
acabar con la crisis en ucrania en medio
de los diálogos rusia no cesa el
movimiento militar ha concentrado cerca
de 100 mil soldados y armamento pesado
en la frontera una actitud desafiante
que ha llevado el secretario de estado
estadounidense anthony blinken a
apresurarse a viajar para encontrarse
con el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski
y
la idea de que ucrania es el agresor en
estas situaciones absurda es rusia la
que invadió a ucrania hace casi 8 años
es rusia la que ocupa militarmente parte
de ucrania en crimea es rusia la que hoy
está alimentando una guerra en el este
de ucrania
el departamento de estado también ha
expresado su preocupación con el
traslado de más fuerzas rusas a belarús
según minsk los ejercicios conjuntos que
comenzarán a partir de febrero suponen
una amenaza para kiev la capital
ucraniana en caso de agresión en
paralelos representantes alemanes y
rusos se reunieron este martes el
gasoducto nord stream 2 que enviará gas
ruso directamente a alemania por el mar
báltico volvió a ser uno de los
principales puntos sobre la mesa por
primera vez berlín se mostró dispuesto a
frenar el proyecto en caso de una
invasión rusa en ucrania rusia rechazó
esas amenazas
nord stream 2 es el mayor proyecto
comercial de la última década destinado
a garantizar la seguridad energética
alemana y europea recordamos a nuestros
colegas alemanes que los intentos de
politizar este proyecto serían las
acciones rusas contrastan con su
disposición para dialogar el turno será
para eeuu cuándo blinken se reúna con su
homólogo ruso el viernes en ginebra
en eeuu este miércoles se activa la red
5 gente sin embargo compañías como
verizon y haití en ti han aplazado la
activación alrededor de los aeropuertos
esto ante la preocupación de posibles
interferencias con los sistemas de
navegación de los aviones algunas
aerolíneas suspendieron los vuelos a la
unión americana argumentando la
incertidumbre por el despliegue de estos
servicios les contamos más en este
reporte
los gigantes de la telefonía móvil de
verizon han pausado temporalmente la
activación de sus servicios 5g cerca de
las pistas de los aeropuertos de eeuu
por tercera vez las compañías que han
gastado miles de millones de dólares
para actualizarse se dieron ante las
preocupaciones de las aerolíneas que
aseguran que las señales móviles podrían
interferir con los sistemas de
navegación de los aviones la
multinacional estadounidense y tiente se
quejó de que los reguladores han tenido
dos años para prepararse para el 5 g
estamos frustrados por la incapacidad de
la administración federal de aviación
para hacer lo que casi 40 países han
hecho que es desplegar de forma segura
la tecnología 5g sin interrumpir los
servicios de aviación y le instamos a
hacerlo de manera oportuna la casa
blanca respondió
nuestro objetivo es llegar a una
solución en torno al despliegue del se
encoge que mantenga el máximo nivel de
seguridad el tiempo que minimice las
interrupciones en los viajes de
pasajeros intur el domingo la
administración federal de aviación
autorizó al 45 por ciento de los vuelos
comerciales en eeuu a aterrizar en los
aeropuertos donde se usará el servicio
coge las aerolíneas advirtieron que
miles de vuelos no despegarían si se
activa como estaba previsto las
preocupaciones se centran en el servicio
de banda aceh que utiliza el 5g para
ofrecer mayor velocidad y una cobertura
más amplia las aerolíneas dicen que no
hay suficiente espacio entre ese
servicio y la frecuencia que usan los
aviones para medir la altitud a pesar de
la preocupación por la seguridad el
servicio 5g ya se utiliza cerca de los
aeropuertos en gran parte de la unión
europea y en corea del sur hasta ahora
sin ningún problema la organización
mundial de la salud advirtió que la
pandemia está lejos de terminar el
organismo sostiene que aunque los
contagios van en aumento la cantidad de
muertos se mantiene estable sin embargo
los efectos de la variante omicron están
sobrecargando cada vez más a los centros
de salud y a sus profesionales lado ms
insistió nuevamente en la necesidad de
repartir las vacunas equitativamente y
también señaló que es posible que surjan
más linajes del coronavirus
o micro con sirius omicron continúa
barriendo en el mundo
last week la semana pasada hubo más de
18 millones de casos reportados que
dices
la cantidad de muertes se mantiene
estable por el momento pero nos preocupa
el impacto económico que está teniendo
en los trabajadores de la salud ya
agotados y en los sistemas de salud
sobrecargados en over the health systems
en algunos países los casos parecen
haber alcanzado su punto máximo
lo que da la esperanza de que lo peor de
esta última ola haya terminado pero
ningún país está fuera de peligro
todavía siento estas son otras noticias
del cobi 19 en el mundo francia registra
un nuevo récord de casos diarios de kobe
19 al confirmar casi 465 mil además
cerca de 3 mil 900 personas están en
unidades de cuidados intensivos desde
finales de diciembre de la nación
europea enfrenta un repunto de casos que
no había padecido en toda la pandemia
en brasil el comí 19 también está
repuntando en el gigante sudamericano
registró su segundo mayor número de
casos en las últimas 24 horas superando
los 137 mil así las cifras se
multiplicaron por 8 en las últimas dos
semanas una cantidad semejante de
contagios no se veía desde septiembre de
2021 cuando el país se enfrentaba a su
peor momento de la pandemia
el presidente de paraguay mario abdo
benítez dio positivo por kobe 19 el
ministerio de salud pública afirmó que
el mandatario tiene síntomas leves
benítez ya estaba aislado pues su esposa
silvana lópez moreira ya se había
contagiado el presidente está vacunado
con dos dosis de modernas
en otras noticias la franco-colombiana
ingrid betancourt confirmó que aspirará
a la presidencia de colombia esta
política dijo que quería romper las
cadenas que por décadas han mantenido a
colombia en la corrupción y la violencia
betancourt estuvo secuestrada por la
entonces guerrilla de las farc durante
más de seis años parte del tiempo sus
captores la tuvieron encadenada ella ya
había sido candidata presidencial en
2002 y fue justo en un viaje de campaña
que la secuestraron
que voy a ser parte de esta coalición
de centro esperanza como candidata a la
presidencia y que voy a trabajar desde
este instante sin descanso de sol a sol
para hacer su presidente y yo he venido
hoy a exigir que se indemnice se
compense y se repare
a cada hijo a cada hija a cada padre a
cada madre de todas las familias de
nuestro país el primer ministro
británico boris johnson negó haberle
mentido al parlamento hace una semana
sobre la fiesta que realizó en mayo de
2020 en su residencia oficial cuando el
país se encontraba en pleno
confinamiento por la pandemia
johnson aseguró que nadie le advirtió
que el evento iba en contra de las
restricciones previamente dominique
cummings su antigua mano derecha había
indicado que tanto él como otro
funcionario alertaron por escrito que
debía cancelar la fiesta al menos 20
conservadores del parlamento confirmaron
que planean enviar cartas solicitando
una moción de censura contra el primer
ministro
la multinacional estadounidense
microsoft anunció la compra por 68 mil
700 millones de dólares de la empresa de
videojuegos activision blizzard una de
las mayores desarrolladoras de
videojuegos del mundo y la creadora de
productos como candy craft o call of
duty de acuerdo con microsoft esta
adquisición que es la mayor en su
historia la convierte en la tercera
mayor compañía del sector de los
videojuegos está previsto que la
operación se complete este año una vez
recibida la aprobación de los
reguladores
y hasta aquí las noticias ustedes
esperen más en minutos
[Música]